This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. How many times have you heard the phrase, just trust your gut, go with your instinct, or when you know you just know. When we hear those phrases in response to a situation where we really just need advice,
we're feeling uncertain, it can make the situation feel even more confusing, especially if you are someone who is naturally anxious, because feelings of anxiety and a gut instinct often feel completely similar and are incredibly hard to differentiate. Self-doubt, intuition, generalized anxiety, even excitement, they all feel the same. They all operate on the same axis. So how can we ensure that we are making the right choices, that we are choosing the right path, questioning the right things when we can't always tell what to focus on and what to ignore? Well, today, that is exactly what we are talking about. We are going to talk about how to distinguish between intuition and anxiety.
And let me tell you, I think it is so important to have this conversation in our 20s because there are so many big life decisions to be made during this decade and so much insecurity and doubt in general. And if we let ourselves be led by fear, thinking that an emotion that powerful must be a a sign. Fear must be a sign. I don't think that we give ourselves the lives that we want. And fear in these situations or anxiety cannot be the master of our fate or the master of our destiny or whatever you want to call it. Knowing the difference between my gut instinct and my fear, it has been a process of trial and error for me. I used to be such a back and forth kind of person.
I would constantly need other people's input. I would take a leap of faith and then I would back down because I began to doubt my own instincts. But around three years ago, I think I experienced just this huge mental shift in general across all areas of my life. And around that time, I basically decided that for three months, I was just going to go with whatever thing I had decided to do first. So whether it was what restaurant to pick, what movie to watch, what person to date, I had to be decisive and I had to base it on my first thought and my first decision. And I definitely got things wrong during that period, but I think I came out of it with such a strong inner voice.
And there have been so many times where I have really not trusted my inner voice and been disappointed. And every single time I have been, it's almost been really. reaffirming to me when, like what that sounds like, when it's an instinct, when it's my intuition, and it's so loudly calling me and I ignore it, it feels terrible, but it also just helps me, again, reinforce what that voice means to me and when to listen to it. Now, don't get me wrong, I still experience anxiety when it comes to my decisions, but I think I can now really sit back and appreciate it and have a conversation with my anxiety almost, than allowing it to dictate what I do in life.
When we confuse intuition and anxiety, I think a lot of things can happen. We can become very obsessive over particular thoughts that are unhelpful because we think they mean more than they do when really they are just thoughts. We can make decisions because we're panicked that actually end up being ones that we regret. We leave someone we shouldn't.
We turn away from an opportunity we shouldn't. we quit when we shouldn't. Or we don't make decisions that we need to make because we think our anxiety is trying to tell us something. When really, if you think about it, it's just trying to keep us small and it's also trying to keep us safe in a way. These are the mistakes that I want us to make less of. And the thing I'm most excited for in this episode is this questionnaire slash checklist that I have that I use for myself for judging whether a thought I'm having is an anxious thought or an intuitive guide or an intuitive signal. And it's literally one that you could take, you can bring any question, any thought you're having
and you could apply it and put it through this framework and you would have your answer. Is this a thought I should listen to? Is it coming from an anxious place or an intuitive place? I also want to talk about how intuition and anxiety feel in our bodies and in our minds why they're similar, how they're different, when to know the difference, and most importantly, I think, how to truly strengthen our intuition, how to make sure that it is a voice that we hear over the voices of Afia, but also over the voices of a lot of other people who have opinions about our lives,
as they always will. So there was definitely a time that I needed this episode myself. Maybe I still need it, but now I get the chance to make it for you all. So I hope you learn something. I hope it makes you recognize something about yourself. I hope it quells some of your anxiety. So without further ado, let's talk about the distinction between intuition and anxiety and how to tell the difference. So let's begin by breaking down how each of these feelings, sensations, how they each work.
What is anxiety based in and what is intuition based in? We're going to start with the louder and more persistent or arrogant. of the two we're going to start with anxiety. Anxiety, put simply, is our means to survive. It is the alarm system that is meant to protect us against danger by triggering our fight or flight system. Nowadays, this has also been adapted to include fawn and freeze. Basically, anxiety is the first responder.
And they see the incoming danger and they call back to the rest of the body and say, are we going to run? Are we going to fight? Are we going to stay still? I'll be going to make friends. Sometimes, I think we often villainize anxiety because, you know, it is pretty terrible for it to be this constant voice in our head. But it actually is really essential. And it does allow us to see our surroundings properly.
It does allow us to be safe. It is an essential part of who we are. When it becomes a problem, though, is when it starts getting fanatical and making up, stranger and stranger scenarios that aren't actually happening, but convincing us that either they will happen or they are happening. So this is known as a distorted anxiety response. Now there is a way we should experience anxiety. Anxiety can be situation or event based. It can be limited both in terms of intensity and frequency. It is important for our protection. And then there is a way that becomes unsustainable and mentally harmful.
And that is when anxiety becomes constant. We are unable to switch off. And it emerges even when nothing is wrong. So if you've ever been sitting on the couch and you're sitting there and your whole life genuinely feels perfect in that moment, there is nothing scary happening around you. And yet you're sitting there almost being like something's wrong. Something's wrong.
I can feel it. I know it. You feel uncertain, you feel scared, and you cannot release that feeling. That is disordered anxiety. And it basically turns us into a bunch of conspiracy theorists. We may, you know, look at a relationship that seems perfectly normal and think, oh my God, they're going to break up with me. Even though there are no signs of that.
Or we think that person is so mad at me. Or I'm going to lose my job. Some big disaster is about to happen. and the worst case scenario is about to happen, even when we have no single piece of evidence for those thoughts or scenarios. We end up spiraling, we end up feeling very panicked, there is this desire to do something, this desire to act, this sense of uneasiness.
We also start to think that this feeling, because it is so significant, it must mean something because it is so loud, it is so hard to dismiss. And the thing is, is that your anxiety is meant to be loud. Anxiety is not meant to be quiet. It was basically made, it was evolved so that it was hard to ignore because we needed to listen to it for it to be useful because it was meant to tell us something important. But because it is so intense, it feels like everything that it is telling us must be coming true. and it will come true and we need to be prepared and we better be listening to every single tiny
piece of thing it tells us even when it's a lie. Now here's the thing about anxiety that I was talking to a friend about this the other day, which is that even like the saying goes that even a wrong clock is right twice a day. So your anxiety is 99% of the time going to be wrong about a situation or a scenario you're in. and then almost by accident, sometimes it will be right. And those are the moments we need to watch out for because we begin to take it as evidence, even though they are so, so rare, we take it as evidence that these feelings we have, which is just simply an overreactive limbic system and our brain trying to interpret the environment,
we take it as a sign. And then other times our anxiety actually creates a self-fulfilling prophecy, which is one of the reasons we confuse it with intuition. So I'm going to use the example again of you think that a friend is mad at you. You think that's your intuition. It's actually just your anxiety. But because you believe that they are mad at you, it begins to inform your behavior. So you become distant.
You become cold. You begin to ignore them as a protective mechanism. And suddenly there is a problem. And you're sitting there going, I told you so. Look, my anxiety was right. It was actually intuition. when really what was happening was this irrational feeling has created this behavior in you subconsciously. So about 30% of us are going to experience an anxiety disorder in our lives.
And like the example I just gave, it does shape our behaviors, our actions and our thoughts. It is such a good liar. Our anxiety is such a good liar. But it's also the part of us that is so vulnerable and genuinely afraid. I always think about anxiety as like a parent who tries to shelter their child from the world and tells their child lies like, you know, the sun is poisonous or other people are evil or these people are the embodiment of Satan. Like, you know, when you watch those weird cult documentaries and the parent, like Carrie, for example, like the parent has told them
something about themselves, not because they hate them, but to protect them because of their own trauma, That's literally how I think about anxiety. This actually brings up an important point, which is the relationship between anxiety and trauma, because we cannot talk about anxiety and the confusion between anxiety and intuition without talking about trauma. So a meta-analysis from 2024, it looked at over a thousand studies and papers written on this topic. Within these papers, there were almost 25,000 combined participants, and it found that, that PTSD makes us more anxiety sensitive. Our anxiety response is deeply informed by our past and the
things that have caused us extreme pain and hurt. And trauma is just going to scramble the parts of our brain that can think rationally about something because if you've been through something really terrible, be it relationship trauma, family trauma, childhood trauma, even like a natural disaster, anything like that, basically that has almost rewired how your brain sees threats and how it sees information because you survived that. Your brain is now almost locked in on those memories and believes that those memories are useful. So the things that you saw right before, I don't know, the boat sunk or right before the relationship exploded, your brain has still got those in storage and is going to bring them out and use them as almost like a tester for what, you know, that experience would
look like in the future. How do we avoid it, essentially? I feel like that just, I just rambled there and that maybe didn't make any sense. I just like to give the example of being afraid of flying, right? And having experienced a traumatic flying event. That has happened to me. I had a really traumatic fly at once. It was just, I'm not even going to go into details, but it was just so awful. It was so awful. people were crying, people were screaming, it was genuinely traumatic. It may have not led to PTSD, but what it did lead to was a heightened anxiety response in relation to flying. And because I went through that, my brain is now so hyper aware of how scary that felt that that anytime I get on a plane, I'm thinking, oh my God, this twinge in my stomach, that's a sign.
Because I felt anxious when I thought the plane was crashing. And so this new feeling must be like this same feeling that. is actually just a natural response to an unknown, must be telling me something. This is all to say, obviously anxiety is going to feel a lot like a sign sometimes because it is loud, because it is sometimes linked to very emotional, heightened situations, and because it's fear-based and we are naturally prone to listen to fear. Okay, now we really need to discuss intuition. If you want to hear like a full debrief on anxiety, you can listen to.
I think it's episode 31 on the anxious mind, but now it's important to distinguish between anxiety and intuition here. Intuition is something that is sometimes lumped in with a bunch of other concepts. Paranoia, cognitive biases, emotional thinking, anxiety, of course, a gut instinct, our inner voice. Whatever you want to call it, whatever people confuse it as, basically intuition describes the way that we can just sense that something is not quite right without needing. rational proof in that moment. It is this strange ability to pick up on cues from another person
or our environment or from our senses that is telling us something that might not be something we can admit to ourselves or we can say out loud, but we can feel it. So I found this really amazing article that kind of broke down the four types of intuition. So there's clairvoyance, which is kind of almost having visions or seeing images of something that's about to happen, honestly quite spiritual, very rare. There's clair sentience, which is like a gut reaction that could include feeling really intense bodily sensations or feelings. There's clear cognizance, which is when you're kind of sitting there and you just feel
this like piece of knowledge drop into your head. One example I give as people who say they knew the queen was going to die the day before she did. it felt like this weird intuitive, oh my God, like mystical thing. And then there is clear audience, which is hearing short phrases, voices, sounds that feel like some kind of direct message. Obviously, there's a lot of overlap with that last one with schizophrenia or schizoaffective disorder. Essentially, it's just how you hear your intuition when your intuition is at a normal, balanced level.
Now, some people are going to define intuition as a very spiritual. spiritual or magical phenomenon. And until about 20 years ago, the scientific community would have probably agreed and it would have told you that it was garbage and it was just mystical thinking. But more and more evidence is coming out that points to the fact that our gut instinct and our intuition has a very strong scientific basis. And it does occur on almost a cellular level, on a social level, a physical level and a collective level as well. I personally have a deep belief in intuition, if that is not obvious.
I'm going to tell you about this crazy story that actually happened to me that felt like intuition at work and probably even saved my life. So around five years ago, I was living in Canberra and it was around 11 p.m. at night, almost 12, and me and my boyfriend at the time decided to go and get McDonald's, like a drive-thru McDonald's. I don't know why. I think we just were like, we'd watched a movie, we were still awake, we really felt like a McFaright. Honestly, that's just a silly detail.
You don't need to know that. We go through this drive-thru, we pull out, and we pull into this like four-way intersection with two lanes going either way. We pull up to the light. There are no other cars around. We're listening to music. And the light for me to turn right at this intersection goes green. and I'm sitting there and I just don't go forward.
And my boyfriend at the time looks at me and goes, what are you doing? Like, why aren't you moving? And I kind of just looked at him and was like, oh, I don't know. Right at that point, I turned back to the road and I went to go forward and at that very moment, this car going probably around 100 kilometres an hour, ran the red light and would have completely hit us. It would have hit us and it probably would have killed us. And right behind it, these three to four cop cars pull onto the road and are chasing it. And we are just sitting in the car and I'm just like, holy crap. If I had pulled out onto that road, we would have died. We would have died.
This car would have hit us directly where him and I were sitting and it would have just been the end. And that's, like, we literally pulled over and we're just like in shock. Like, I cannot even explain that feeling of just being like, wow. And later that, then we called our friend, I don't even know what happened. I think we like texted our friends and we're like, you're not going to believe what just happened. And they go on the news and they go into like our local news page in Canberra. And there's a car that has been like in pursuit by the police. And an hour later, like it's been basically it's a high speed chase. And I don't know what it was in that moment when, you know,
I'm in the car listening to music and the light turns green and I see it turn green and I did not go. And some part of me says that was just intuition. The thing is, I'm quite a scientific person. I love the science. I love the evidence. And for a while I was really trying to find an answer because how do we explain moments like that? We've all had a moment like that.
There are a few theories as to what causes this intuition that stops us or tells us to go or is like a calling. The first explanation is obviously one of fate and destiny and mysticism and a higher power controlling everything. Call it God. The universe Allah, some power is moving all these parts. Now this one's hard to prove, obviously, because it's hard to prove the existence of something you can't and that doesn't have a scientific measure to it, but that's one take on it. The psychology, though, says two things. Intuition is this emotionally charged, rapid, unconscious process
whereby our brain is basically using information that we've never acknowledged or seen before to influence our actions. So basically, when we look at the world, our brain is really good at just selecting what is important to us because we do have, finite cognitive resources. It cannot process every single little thing in our environment at once and give all that information to us to consciously process. All that information though, it still exists and it's still being processed. You may not consciously have noticed the car speeding down towards you, but part of your brain did and told you to stop. You may not have
consciously seen the suspicious shadow in the alleyway. Some part of your brain. did and it kind of cut over all the noise and said don't go down there don't go forward don't do that thing that's the first explanation basically your unconscious mind noticing things quicker than you faster than you silently the second explanation is based on learning and how our brain really predicts things based on past experience and yeah basically it learns from what we've been through before so this is the theory that was put forward by the neuroscientist Joel Pearson. He runs a lab on neuroscience and intuition called Future Mind Labs at UNSW here in Sydney. And I'm going to explain this explanation the way he does, which is using a coffee shop. So you write a new coffee shop. Let's say you're
walking around London, you're walking around Brazil, you're walking around Tokyo, some city, you've never been before. And you want to get a coffee, you want to get some lunch. Now, you've been to heaps of cafes before. And when you were in those environments, your brain processed all of these pieces of information, the temperature, the music, the coffee machine, how clean the floor was, the decor, how warm it was. And you've just basically learned what parts of an atmosphere or an, or an environment are going to predict the kind of food and experience and coffee that you want based on all these prior learnings. So as you're looking for a cafe, you're standing in the entrance, your intuition is applying those learnings to all this conscious information that's
happening right now to help you make a decision based on a gut feeling. This is why you might have a gut instinct about a bad friend or that someone is lying to you. It's because you've probably encountered a situation before. And although you may not have picked up on some of the information that came with this situation, part of your brain did. And now it's pulling that information out of storage to help you make the best decision in this moment now. There is another component of intuition, and it's talked about a lot less, and it's this kind of ancient kind of knowledge. Knowledge passed down through generations that feels like it's in our DNA, even in ourselves. You may not have encountered a situation before, but there is some
human part of you that feels very familiar with it and knows how to act and some kind of of deja vu. I honestly think it's because there's some ancestor, some experience from your past that it's in your blood, it's in your bones, it's been passed down through you. You can call it spirit, you can call it whatever. I know this sounds very woo-woo. It's an ancient human knowledge that informs how you see the world and informs your intuition and your gut instinct. I want to tell another story this time about my mom. When she was my age, she was traveling around the world, doing fun, fabulous things. And she was in Indonesia.
She was on a mountain that she knew was an active volcano. And it hadn't explored for a while. I think it was semi-dormant. She's walking up this volcano, doing this hike. And she just gets the sense that this is going to erupt. Something's not right. And she runs down the mountain. She sprints down the mountain and it erupts.
like, I don't know if it was the day later. It was after she got down the mountain. But within a very short period of time, the volcano had erupted. And from what I can remember of this story, no one was there with her. No one had told her. She just had this very human sense. And it was almost like some ancestors,
some human person in her past had encountered this. And there was a knowledge there that was passed on. And I remember her telling me, she felt like she needed to move and she needed to hustle, but she didn't feel anxious about the thought. She didn't feel like there was anything to do other than to act. She was very certain. And I think this is what intuition feels like. It feels very calm and self-assured. There is no doubt. There is not a thousand possible outcomes or explanation running through your head. The way that that, you know, that's sometimes what happens with anxiety.
You're sitting there. Oh, like, this could happen or this could happen or this could happen. It's serving you up a thousand different possibilities. With intuition, that's not the case. There's one explanation, one prediction. You feel it in your body. It is stable. It is certain.
It is confident. Most people also obviously say you can feel it in your stomach. That's the term gut instinct. That's where it comes from. Now, the science behind this sensation is very, very cool. Scientists don't call the stomach the second brain for no reason. There's very good reason because there is a vast neural network of over 100 million neurons lining your entire digestive system.
And every single year, more and more evidence emerges that there is this bidirectional communication pathway between the brain and the gut. In other words, you might feel your, emotions or certain sensations in your stomach before you consciously process them. They're known by another name. They're called gut signals and a 2020 paper looked at whether they could be trusted. And it did find that emotional stress and cues have an immediate impact on the gut in a way that we may be quicker to recognize than a passing thought or than any other kind of sensory
information. That's what the gut instinct is. As to whether we can trust our intuition, I can't go into all the studies because there are so, so many. And the answer is, it really depends. It really depends. But by and large, we do need this part of ourselves, this unconscious intelligence. A 2006 study that I read that looked at this found that people were better able to make a decision, under like chaotic circumstances when they went with what they initially thought, rather than those situations where they had time to really think about it, especially when we have more options. So if we're thinking about intuition and a big life choice,
especially one in our 20s, if you just applied reason and rationality to however many choices you have, you would not make a good decision because you would get too caught up in the data. There are certain moments like that one. where you have to just trust what is being fed to you, what information that you may not be able to label is being told to you that is helping you make a choice. I also think, you know, human emotion and to some extent,
human relationships aren't always properly represented in rational thought. There are things about human relationships that cannot be presented in facts or figures or pro-cons lists. And so listening out for that emotional directive that you'll, are being given and whatever direction you're being called to is really, really important. Otherwise, you end up confused, robotic, almost mathematical at times. The question now is, how do we tap into that inner voice when sometimes it does just feel like anxiety? We spend a lot of time talking about both of those things.
Let's put it together after this very short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator of available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are
freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What The hell does George Bush got to do a little count? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness, this month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood,
pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle
to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been through, the same thing. Grega lesbian, Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So knowing what we know now, why do we confuse intuition and anxiety? Well, we are. often confuse them because they feel the same and they elicit very similar thoughts and sensations. In particular, if you are someone who is already anxious, you are going to be hypervigilant
to even the smallest cues or signs of danger or signs that you should or shouldn't be doing something. And so your brain is going to naturally apply a deeper meaning to things that sometimes is just fear, sometimes it's just catastrophic thinking, sometimes it's just worry. and we confuse those sensations for an intuitive thought. Here are some of the other reasons that we tend to get them confused. I think, to start off with, they both often occur in response to uncertain situations. And so with both intuition and anxiety,
they often are going to come up when there is some kind of unknown. And that's something we never enjoy as humans. And because in that situation, we're already stressed, it can be hard to tell the difference. They can both often feel a little bit irrational. Like, I don't know why I feel this way, I just do. In terms of anxiety, the reason you just feel this way is because your mind is, I don't know, just on high alert and dysregulated in terms of how you're processing fear.
In terms of intuition, sometimes it's because you're just seeing something that your brain isn't consciously knowing is there. They also both originate from within us. even if it's different corners of the mind. If anxiety was all situation-based or was just what someone else had to say, it would be very easy to discredit it. But because both of them,
intuition and anxiety, are coming through some of the same channels, they can get kind of confused. They also, like I said, elicit some of the same physical sensations, specifically that gut signal or sensation. For anxiety, that can feel like nausea. Sometimes that feels the same.
as a gut instinct, so it's easily confused. They both also feel important to listen to. So as much as we kind of hate an anxious feeling, it is an important feeling and it's very hard for our brain to ignore it. The same with intuition. It's there, they're loud, and often they are directed towards something that feels emotionally salient to us. We're not going to feel intuitive or anxious about what bag to take to the gym or what pen
to use. We're going to feel anxious and intuitive about very profound big things like finances, relationships, life choices. So they sit in the same ecosystem. And finally, they're both trying to guide us to make a certain decision. Intuition wants us to make a good decision. Anxiety wants us to make the decision that keeps us safe. Either way, they're both working on our brain to kind of give it the best argument as to what path to take. We've talked about how they're similar. How do they differ? This is the real thing we want to know.
Well, where anxiety is urgent and rushed, and it will always make you feel like you need to do something immediately, like a bad boss with a bad way of time management, intuition is going to let you take your time. Intuition will not push you. It will not rush you towards a decision, even if it's an important choice. Intuition I've found also feels remarkably
calm. It's like this steady feeling in your whole body, this like real sense of like, yeah, this is what I need to do. And sometimes you even are just like, I can't explain it. I just know and it's not scary. It's just knowledge. On the other hand, anxiety tends to be very uncomfortable. There's a lot of restlessness. There's a lot of jitteriness. It's movement. It's chaos. It's energy. Like we said before, this is also an important distinction. Intuition is singular. Anxiety is plural. Intuition will often give you one answer, one scenario, one hypothetical, whereas anxiety
will give you several. Intuition is also present, focused. It's based on what is happening now, whilst anxiety is focused on the future and it's very obsessive. And it's based in fear, whereas intuition is based in freedom. I think the best way I can describe the difference is that we often confuse anxiety as intuition all the time, but very rarely the other way around. We never think that intuition is just anxiety, because intuition is so absolutely sure of itself, and there's often no fear. I know this feels rather abstract, so I thought I'd give you a bit of a checklist.
Say you are listening to this episode for a specific situation to you. One, I probably don't know. There's something coming up, though. Some part of you is scared. Some part of you wants the right answer. Some part of you doesn't know which feeling you're having right now to trust and which one to ignore. So I want to give you a checklist for whether the thought you're having is an intuitive thought or an anxious thought. To begin with, does the thought you're having?
start with what if? If it does, it's an anxious thought. What if this happens? There's no what ifs with intuition. Secondly, how long have you been thinking about this hypothetical? If it's persistent and subtle, that's intuition. If it's just showed up today and it's coming in waves of fear and overthinking, that's anxiety. Does this thought limit or expand you?
If it traps you, it's anxiety. because anxiety really likes to keep things safe by keeping them the same. If it's intuition, it's going to expand you and guide you, even if it feels uncomfortable. And that's why we cannot rely on discomfort alone to tell whether a thought is intuitive or anxious. Now, does this thought push you more towards self-trust or does it make you doubt yourself more? Self-trust, intuition, self-doubt, anxiety. Do you feel confident in this decision deep down or are you seeking constant reassurance? So are you going to friends, family, Reddit pages, trying to tell, is this the right decision?
Is it not the right decision? If you feel confident deep down, it's intuition. If you're needing reassurance, it's anxiety. If you sit quietly and you breathe and you're all alone and you feel like you're trying to bring yourself peace, Does the thought go away? Does it fade when you relax? If that's the case, it's anxiety. If it's still there and it's steady, it's not causing you any harm, it's intuition. This is my checklist. And I want you to write these down. Remember that this episode is here for the next time you have a thought that you think is anxious, that you think is misleading. Test it against this framework. I think if you're so,
still struggling to delineate between these two emotions. The final way to really tell is that intuition is going to respond positively to action, and anxious thought will respond positively to slowing down. So, if the thought gets louder, the less you do, you have confused intuition with anxiety. If the thought gets louder, the more you try and change and escape, you've confused anxiety with intuition. That's really, I know I've given you a lot of ways of telling this, but this is really the one. With all that in mind, how do we improve our ability to hear our inner voice and our inner directive and what it wants from us?
Matter of fact, how do we also improve our ability to tune out our anxiety and to stop it cutting over the intuitive frequency? The first thing I do when I really want to tap into what I truly want and I'm thinking is that I spend time in solitude. I take a step back from everything. I spend time by myself, particularly in nature. I find that firstly that calms my anxiety. I always say this. The best way to regulate your nervous system is to put it back into the environment it was made to work in. Your nervous system, your stress response, it was made.
for the wild, it was made for this so-called natural habitat. That's where it's going to be regulated best. So being outdoors helps with that. It also makes me more focused on what I truly want. So that solitude part is really, really essential. I also think if you're trying to tap into your intuition, spending more time alone, it's not just that it's a cure for anxiety in some way. It's also that it stops you from approval and opinion seeking. So that is often a similar. of someone who was quite anxious and quite obsessive in their thoughts, you're often asking people for their opinion constantly because you can't trust yourself. Being away from that temptation is really helpful. And I think when we are constantly looking for other people's validation
of our decisions and what they think, we do cut ourselves off from our self-knowledge because our own thoughts, we start to question them in favor of what someone else thinks. And really, what do they know? Like what do they know about what you feel? Probably not much. They're applying their own intuition about their life to your circumstances when your circumstances are probably entirely different. And there's this incredible study from 2023 actually conducted in Australia that found those of us who spend more time alone, we are more self-aware and we are more satisfied in terms of autonomy. Autonomy being our ability to make decisions for ourselves and believe they are good decisions. Now I will say small caveat here, you can't spend more than 75% of your time
alone. Another study kind of gave us that figure, also another study from 2023. So finding that balance between being able to appreciate solitude and isolation in a sense, but also not tip too far over the edge, really important. The other way to strengthen your intuition is to be patient. Don't always look for a sign. Don't rush it. Rushing is an anxious game. That is anxiety's favorite game to play. And it will have you looking for signs where there aren't any, leading you to read too much into small things, leading you to make the wrong decisions. Basically what I'm trying to say is don't feel like you need to change everything at once and that every discomfort is a problem. sometimes discomfort, it is growth.
It is okay to sit in a period that feels strange and odd for a little while without feeling like it's indicating a problem. Let me give some examples of this. When you are in a new relationship, especially if you're in a new relationship where you've previously been in an unhealthy one, sometimes that's going to feel a little bit painful. There are these growing pains in a relationship. it doesn't mean that you should trust that discomfort solely. Another example is in a new job.
You know, I always say the first three months of a new job are really, really hard. It doesn't mean it's the wrong decision. What about like moving to a new city? That's another one. You're going to feel uncomfortable. When you move to a new city, that discomfort does not mean that you necessarily have made the wrong decision. My rule is always the six-month rule. if it's three months for a job, it's six months for a new city.
If you still hate it at six months, then you can say, oh, maybe I didn't trust my gut instinct. But yeah, I just think that be patient with choices that you make, just because they aren't working out right now, doesn't mean that you were wrong. I would also say in the opposite direction, notice patterns in past decisions. So reflect on times when you made the wrong decision.
You can arguably say, Tang, I really made a wrong decision. Right before you made that decision in the weeks, days, minutes before you made that decision, was there another decision calling you that you ignored? That was probably your gut instinct. That was probably your intuition. Remember that feeling? Remember it and apply it to the situations you're in now.
Do you feel something similar at the moment? And try some trial and error. You know, sometimes the best way to get more in touch with your intuition is to make mistakes that prove to you what your intuition is not. Trial and error sucks, but sometimes if you feel strongly about something, you have to follow through with it, see what happens, and that's going to be the easiest way for you to tell what anxiety feels like for you versus what intuition feels like for you. And if that feels very big and scary, you can start with very small, low stakes risks, just to build confidence in your intuition by making minor intuitive decisions.
So trying a new activity, if you feel called to talk to someone on the street, if you feel called to, I don't know, have a connection with someone, do it. It's so low stakes. I feel like it's going to be fine. Those kinds of things are a really great practice routine. They're really good training wheels. Now for managing your anxiety, this is a whole other ballgame, a whole other pit of snakes. Like I said, we have an episode on this. I'm going to leave it in the description. It's actually probably a really good episode to listen to right after this one.
But rapid fire how I address my anxiety when I feel like it's taking over. I create a fear versus reality list. What is a fear thought? What is a reality thought? I put them on separate sides. I repeat them to myself so that I can just reaffirm what I do know to be true. Challenge the what if thinking. Ask yourself, what if the best case scenario happened?
What's the chances of that happening? No more, no less than the worst case. Talk to other people about the feelings that you're having. I would also say stop drinking if you're going through a real anxious period and it's interrupting your ability to hear from your intuition. Please stop drinking. We know that alcohol spikes anxiety by initially causing a very calming effect through gabber activity in the brain. But then as it wears off, the brain tries to rebalance those neurotransmitters with glutamate,
which is a very anxious neurotransmitter slash hormone, causing us to feel more anxious. Please stop drinking. Engage in some kind of movement. If I'm anxious and I'm like, okay, why does my intuition slash anxiety tell me this friend hates me? Why do I suddenly believe I'm going to get evicted? Why do I believe this, that, that I immediately dance, I shake, I sing, I do some kind of movement to dispel what is a physical reaction for me. And also get therapy. Get therapy.
People talk about it a lot because it actually works. Surprise, surprise. It's amazing. And so if you really want to tap into your intuition, sometimes you do have to clean out some of the garbage. Sometimes you do have to clean out. some of the thought patterns that you have developed over time to protect yourself that actually are hurting you. All right, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, we've got some listener dilemmas to do with anxiety and intuition. Stay with us.
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush I gotta do a little Kim. Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
So my lovely listeners, if you are a loyal listener of the show, you have been here for a while, you will know that this is a relatively new segment of the podcast. I'm just trialing it out for the next couple of episodes. I'm always down for your feedback, but so many of you would have questions after the episode had gone up. And I wish that I could have answered those questions in the actual episode. So now I'm giving you all the opportunity to ask me those specific questions, dilemmas that you are having before the episode air so I can answer them for you.
If you want to submit a question for an upcoming topic, just make sure you're following me at That Psychology Podcast. We've got some really cool episodes coming up around confidence, around being a late bloomer, around parasocial relationships. I will be asking for your questions and your dilemmas. If you hate this segment, please actually let me know. I really want to hear it because if you guys don't like it, it's going, it's going, it's going, it's gone.
But I want to answer some of the questions that a lot of you kindly submitted today. Let's talk about this first question. Is there any such thing or any time when being led by anxiety is a good thing? The answer is yes. So anxiety causes distress and eustress. U-S-T-R-E-S. It's also known as good stress and it helps boost a lot of really great things, specifically our motivation and our focus.
So there's this law called the Yerkes-Dodson law. And basically it says that anxiety up to a point actually helps improve our performance. Moderate levels of anxiety, of course, will help you better with studying. They help people with deadlines. But it's when we get to an excessive point that it really starts to kind of hurt us. So essentially it's an important balance to have. Anxiety also helps indicate when something requires our attention. I know there are a lot of posts on TikTok and Instagram being like how I got rid of my anxiety.
I cured my anxiety with exercise. I no longer feel anxious. That's probably not a good thing. You do need anxiety sometimes. Otherwise you would be just in a constant state of complete calm and normalcy. and even when stressful things happened, you wouldn't respond to them. It's important to feel that way. Think about your wedding day or like some really important event
where you feel a deep emotional sensation in response to it. You feel nervous. You feel scared. You feel excited. All of that is possible because of anxiety. So yes, there is some level that is important. Question number two. My gut says to leave my boyfriend,
but my anxious self-wonder. if it's just self-sabotage. This is just one person's question, but the amount of times I got something very similar in my DMs was incredible. It's something that a lot of you are obviously quite worried about, and I get it. I really get it because you might be dating someone really, really nice and wonderful, but you're still so young and you worry, is this really what's right for me? You can't tell whether you're going to regret it,
or whether this is really a sign that you need to move on. You don't want to waste their time. What I'm basically describing right here is relationship anxiety or relationship OCD. Don't let the term fool you. It has nothing to do with how we typically see OCD. Essentially, it's this real sense of hypervigilance towards your relationship, whereby you're constantly looking for things that could go wrong, not because they're a bad person, but because you're worried about making the wrong choice.
It sounds like that's something that you may be battling with. On the other hand, it may be a deeper sign. You've noticed something about who you two are as a couple, maybe not consciously yet, but you're feeling it first in your gut. Here's what I would say to you. If you're thinking about what it would look like to leave him more than you are thinking about your future with him, it's probably not the right relationship. The other question I would ask you is,
if you knew you would find love again soon, if you knew that there was someone else out there who would love you as much as this person loves you now, would you leave? Is this just a safe place to land? Is this just an in the meantime relationship? I think be really, really honest with yourself. Also acknowledge, and some people might not be happy with me,
for saying this, but you don't need to make a decision right now. Like I said, intuition gives you time. Anxiety wants you to make a decision right now. Relationships naturally go through ebbs and flows and hard points and great points. It might just be that you're in a bit of a rut right now. I wouldn't want you to give up a really amazing relationship because you've been sold this idea that couples can never have low points. So that's my advice on that one. Question number three asked over. over on Instagram, when do you know if you should push through a comfort zone or if it's actually just unsafe? Good question. It's hard to tell. My natural desire is to always push through. I think that discomfort is something that we as humans are not good at managing, especially in a world where
we don't have to be that uncomfortable if we don't want to be. You know, we truly don't. We can be warm at all times. Most of us, thank gosh, can have food in our belly at all times. We don't experience extreme discomfort anymore. Sometimes a little bit of discomfort is a good thing in this situation, unless you can point to evidence that this is actually going to be an unsafe thing. So can you see examples of it? I think about this with traveling. Are there stories of people being kidnapped in the country you're going to? Are there stories of, or I don't know, Google reviews that the zip line you're going to do is a little bit dangerous. It's important not to be arrogant. Just because we are trusting our intuition doesn't mean that we ignore anxiety at all
points. It is still an important resource. So when you're feeling like there is something that's holding you back and you think that it's because it's unsafe, investigate the evidence for that thing, take a couple of minutes to walk yourself back from the situation. and see it more clearly. I also would say do things to make whatever you're going through feel more safe, but still keep going. So I'm trying to think of what you might be talking about. Say it's your career.
It feels uncomfortable. You think that that's a sign that you're doing the wrong thing. Try and make ways to make your career the way that you're pushing it more comfortable. So try and find different income streams to keep yourself financially stable. maybe that's the source of the discomfort whilst still pushing forward. I think that's like a really great way to say it. Like, you know, people didn't stop building skyscrapers because it was unsafe or uncomfortable.
They kept building them and they built them with safety measures. I think you can do the same in your life. I don't know why I just suddenly used a construction metaphor. I think that's the first time that's ever happened during this podcast. So whoever's questioned that is, you should feel very privileged. All right. final question, I get visceral morning scarries when I wake up. Is it my body trying to tell me something? This is a great question. It's a great question because I get this a lot. I get morning scaries,
probably like five days a week. In terms of whether it's trying to tell you something like about your future or about your life in a mystical way, I don't think so. I think what you're probably experiencing is an elevated cortisol awakening response. So that's morning anxiety. Basically, when you wake up, sometimes we can have this huge surge in our stress hormone cortisol. It's meant to help us just be alive and awake to the world. When that's dysregulated, it can actually go too far the other way and make us quite anxious. It's important not to read too much into it. sometimes I think we can have those again very visceral emotional responses and say that's a sign something's wrong I have cancer someone's going to die no I think that there's often the simplest responses the best one focus on your sleep hygiene focus on trying to bring down your cortisol levels and your stress response before before going to bed and after waking up so no phone in your bedroom you have no idea what a bright blue light in your face before you go to bed and right after you wake up does to your stress response
and your circadian rhythm so try and control that try not to have any bright lights in the bedroom and also review your alarm schedule so it's actually best to wake up naturally at the end of a full sleep cycle if your alarm is like waking you up at like six hours and 55 minutes maybe do it for like seven and a half hours and try and go to bed earlier or get that sleep in because if you're waking up in the middle of a sleep schedule you're waking up in the middle of a dream you're waking up in the middle of REM sleep you are going to be more anxious so again simplest solution is probably the best one I don't think that this is a sign of anything or trying to tell you something other than that your sleep patterns are maybe just a little bit off
and if it keeps happening go and see a doctor they have these really cool sleep studies right now and see if you're feeling it in other areas of your life. If you're not feeling it in other areas of your life, I do think it's just linked back to what this is. I think that is all the questions that I have for today. I'm just reviewing my notes and it looks like that is the case. A long episode, if you have made it this far, you know the deal, a special emoji coming your way.
I want you to leave an emoji that best represents to you what intuition feels like. what does it feel like in your body? What does it feel like in your soul, in your limbs, in your brain? If you've made it that far, this far, I mean, let me know in the comments using that little sneaky sign. As always, I want to thank you for listening. I really loved this episode. Sometimes you just make an episode and you think, fuck, sorry to swear, but like, fuck, I really like this episode. I really like this episode, so I appreciate you listening this far. make sure that you are following me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. We are doing more like listener questions.
So if you want to get involved in some upcoming episodes, that's a great way to do it. Also, if you feel like there is a friend of yours who could really benefit from this episode, make sure to share it with them. I would love to hear from you. I would love to see more people listening, more people following, more people giving us a five-star review if you feel called to do so. But thanks again. Thanks for coming along with me on this really fun. episode ride. Until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk
very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier war fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
On the Look Back at it podcast. In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.